[موسيقى]
أجنبية في
الوقت الحالي نحن على دراية
بالتقارير الصحفية حول هذا الأمر ، وليس لدينا معلومات
في الوقت الحالي لتأكيد هذه
التقارير ولكن مرة أخرى نتعامل معها
بجدية وننظر فيها
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى] من السابق
لأوانه القول ما إذا كان هذا الصاروخ
قد تم إطلاقه من روسيا ،
هناك معلومات محدودة
تعترض على أنني لا أريد أن أقول ذلك
حتى نحقق فيه بالكامل ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه من غير المحتمل
أن عقول المسار الذي تم
إطلاقه منه  روسيا لكننا سنرى
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا
أجنبيًا ،
لقد ناقشنا أيضًا الانفجار في
بولندا بالقرب من الحدود ، ونقدم
دعمنا الكامل لبولندا ومساعدتنا
في التحقيق الجاري ، وسنظل
على اتصال وثيق مع شركائنا في
اليوم التالي  خطوات
[موسيقى]